wir kommen zu unseren nächsten zuschauer
fall liebes betrug ein wahnsinniges wort
und das wirft natürlich viele fragen auf
tatsächlich gibt es wirklich sehr sehr
viele opfer von menschen die tun nur so
als wenn sie sich in jemanden verguckt
haben aber in wahrheit wollen sie halt
unser geld und dazu hat uns sabine wolf
aus gelnhausen auch ein video geschickt
ich habe am 20 juni einmal kempen nennt
über das internet somit jeden tag kamen
immer mehr liebe schwören zu und auch
die aussagen ich vermisse dich so nicht
ich komme es spannend besuchen und ich
nicht unbedingt mit den urlaub fahre
nach singapur und als frau wünschen dass
ich sorge man genau so einen mann zum 20
jetzt kommt der hammer dass er angeblich
kein geld mehr hat sein hotel gezahlt um
die stadt zu essen hat deswegen bittet
15 monate und das im alarmglocken
angegangen das starre länder zu sein so
die nachrichten geschickt habe und er
hatte ein foto von dem mann
zurückverfolgt und schreibt mir dann das
profil von ihm und die fotos geschickt
sind und darum klar machen sollen das
macht was mit ihnen das geht tief in
sich rein
das geht in ihr herz und ihre seele ja
wirklich deutliche worte tatsächlich
sind jetzt auch selbst zugeschaltet
damit wir auch andere vermeintliche
opfer warnen können wo haben sie denn
diesen herren kennen gelernt als sie
gesagt gar nicht bei facebook
angeschrieben total attraktiver mann und
auf alle nachfragen wo ich ein bisschen
skeptisch wurde kam von ihm prompte
antwort
total pressen
und dann groß oder macht er ist
von zwei tagen ist er in ihrem leben und
sechs stunden lang mit ihnen abends und
entwickeln sie natürlich auch gefühle
für diesen mann zu sehen bei mir das
total interessiert an den wald nicht
besuchen kommen
ja ich habe mich darauf gefreut war
voller vorfreude dass er nicht besuchen
kommt und dass sie näher kennen lernen
kann und wie eben in dem video ist
gesehen
kam dann halt der tag dass er mir
schreibt und mich anrufen schlechthin
gilt
und dass er von mir 1500 euro haben will
und ich stehe heute so dankbar meinen
sohn dass er hat während ich mit ihrem
mann getötet habe
der angeblichen istanbul war
herausgefunden hat dass sein profil
komplett komplett gefegt ist und dass er
fotos die wir geschickt hat die dann
auch mehr passend zur situation kam
komplett alles von einem mann stehen hat
und
ich habe jetzt so viel recherchiert im
internet und das ist nicht nur ein mann
der das macht das sind wirklich
organisierte gruppen
die also darauf ist einen
ausgearbeiteten brennt jackson die ihn
geschickt werden sie glauben denn jedes
wort also es unglaublich sie kriegen
blumen geschickt
und wie gesagt
ich fühle und nicht an die
öffentlichkeit gegangen werde es auch
weiter hatten
ich möchte dass frauen gar nicht zum
opfer werden weil sie können sich so
fühle ich mich ausgenutzt benutzt
manipuliert so krass wird sagen ich
fühle mich so es ist so es hat jemand
meine seele vergewaltigt und das ganz
nett sein und deswegen sind sie auch in
dieser sendung ich nehme an camp ganz
dazu wirklich ein wahnsinniger fall der
macht mich wirklich tatsächlich wütend
man wird es immer wieder auch wenn
vielleicht facebook eine gute plattform
ist um jemanden kennenzulernen
wie schätzen sie den fall ein also das
ist eine typische folge wäre der praxis
leider relativ häufig hören und die
betroffenen dann die werden ja denn man
greift das immer unter dem schlagwort
liebes betrug aber das hört sich ja fast
noch ein bisschen harmlos an als wenn
man um die liebe betrogen wurde
aber es geht ja noch um viel mehr es
geht um verletzte gefühle natürlich um
sehr sehr viel gefühle es geht um
hoffnungen und dann geht es noch um geld
das heißt man wird ja nicht nur um die
liebe bedrohung sondern auch um das geld
und das ist dann eine totale demütigung
weil weil sich hinterher fach wie dumm
konnte ich denn sein dass es dass das
passiert ist wir haben ja fälle in denen
noch ganz schlimmere sachen noch viel
mehr passiert also da werden diverse
kredite gegeben es wird behauptet jemand
sei aus der familie gestorben und man
brauchte geld für eine beerdigung man
müsste irgendwie ins heimatland fliegen
weil man da die mutter unterstützen muss
die im sterben liegt und das sind ganz
schlimme dinge das ist so ein spiel mit
dem mitgefühl und da muss man doch ganz
klar sagen das sind ganz klar
betrugsfälle die auch mit erheblichen
strafen geahndet werden und da sollten
betroffene immer strafanzeige erstatten
denn die staatsanwaltschaft ist
sozusagen die einzige behörde die die
möglichkeit hat eventuell hinter diese
leute zu kommen festzustellen wo die
wohnen und wenn wir dann strafverfahren
haben und da ist wirklich ein
angeklagter dann besteht die möglichkeit
sich dort durch ein sogenanntes
adhäsionsverfahren anzuschließen und
dann kann man in diesem strafverfahren
seinen eigenen schaden zivilrechtlich
einklagen und bekommt dann geld zurück
und dann werden oftmals durch das
gericht auflagen erteilt das eben auch
gezahlt wird das heißt die erfolgsquote
wenn man strafanzeigen
er startet und jemanden auch bekommen
sind gar nicht mal so schlecht